[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente esto es lo que veremos hoy el
6 de junio los mexicanos acuden a las
urnas para las elecciones más grandes de
su historia más de 20.000 cargos
públicos están en juego en estos
comicios que son vistos como un
referendo a la gestión del presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador pues podría
perder la mayoría absoluta en la cámara
de diputados
dos reformas y tres funcionarios caídos
pero las protestas antigubernamentales
siguen en colombia ya se cumplió un mes
desde el inicio del paro nacional en
medio de la preocupación de la comunidad
internacional por las denuncias de
violaciones a los derechos humanos y se
cumple un año del asesinato del afro
estadounidense george white a manos del
policía blanco directo a bing un caso
que desató una ola de protestas a nivel
nacional e internacional y motivó una
revisión profunda del racismo
estructural en el mundo
y vamos de inmediato a mexico que entra
en la recta final para las elecciones
del 6 de junio las más importantes de su
historia debido a la magnitud más de 94
millones de personas están convocadas a
las urnas para elegir a 500 diputados
federales y casi 20.000 cargos estatales
la violencia ha empañado el proceso
electoral tan solo esta semana murió a
tiros una candidata municipal en medio
de un acto de campaña con alma barragán
ya son 88 los políticos asesinados 75%
de ellos serán opositores según la
consultora select nuestro corresponsal
mario carbonero nos amplia desde ciudad
de mexico
es obra del destino que guillermo
valencia este ángulo
y la noche del 8 de mayo un grupo de
pistoleros disparó contra la camioneta
en la que se suponía que viajaba pero él
había cambiado de vehículo
por lo que creemos que eran gatilleros
profesionales que alguien contrató para
venir a hacer este trabajo y que tenían
tiempo siguiendo mis pasos el caso de
valència es sólo una de las 101
agresiones que según cifras oficiales se
han dado en el proceso electoral al
corte del 21 de mayo
ese día guillermo hizo ajustes en su
campaña me iba a caminar me iba los
tianguis a los mercados ya no pos
mi actividad pública disminuyó
drásticamente
y tú
y ahora si trae una cometa blindadas no
la traía
un amigo pues usó un chaleco antibalas
ante la violencia en el proceso
electoral el gobierno federal puso en
marcha una estrategia de coordinación
integral si se definen acciones para
proteger a los candidatos señor
candidato es
visitas domiciliarias oa su lugar de
campaña puede ser también contar con
escolta con un auto
preparado para ello es decir el nivel de
riesgo es directamente proporcional al
nivel de apoyo
si las autoridades reconocen sólo 13
homicidios pero consultoras como
integralia y jet elec señalan varias
decenas más algunos aspirantes se han
retirado otras amenazas pero valencia
sigue en el proceso electoral más grande
y complejo de la historia del país
pero también tiene elecciones del 6 de
junio y un acto de violencia también
empaña la campaña al menos 16 personas
murieron entre ellas 4 menores de edad
en un atentado en la zona conocida como
vrae donde operan varios grupos
delincuenciales y remanentes del grupo
terrorista sendero luminoso que se
convirtieron en narcotraficantes sin
embargo algunos sectores aseguran que no
se trata del modus operandi de ese grupo
y que sería una estrategia para influir
en el voto entre keiko fujimori pedro
castillo les explicamos
un genocidio así lo calificó el ejército
de perú las autoridades responsabilizan
a los remanentes del sendero luminoso de
la masacre que tuvo lugar en el corazón
de la amazonía peruana un grupo de
delincuentes terroristas de la
organización terrorista sendero luminoso
que actúa en el vrae provistos con armas
de fuego
incursionaron en el sector playa a
orillas del río sin pichar hiato del
centro poblado san miguel' de ln capital
del distrito vizcatán del n satipo junín
denominado cuchi pampa
en donde existen bares cantinas y se
ejerce la prostitución como consecuencia
de la incursión terrorista fueron
asesinados por proyectiles de arma de
fuego arma blanca fuego y objetos
contundente 14 personas entre ellos dos
niños calcinados la remota región
montañosa es donde se produce el 75 por
ciento de la coca del país donde se cree
que los remanentes del grupo maoísta
trabajan con traficantes de droga la
policía informó que dejaron panfletos
advirtiendo a la gente de no votar por
keiko fujimori en las elecciones
presidenciales del 6 de junio la hija
del ex presidente alberto fujimori
condenado por delitos de lesa humanidad
se enfrenta al candidato de izquierda
pedro castillo fujimori ha dedicado su
campaña a prometer que acabará con los
grupos rebeldes comunistas ambos
condenaron la masacre y solidaridad
a las familias
de las víctimas que acaban de ser
asesinados lamento profundamente
nuevamente actos sangrientos están
ocurriendo en nuestro país la elección
es una de las más polarizadas de la
historia del país miles marcharon contra
la candidatura de fujimori además de
tener cargos en su contra por corrupción
los peruanos rechazan el mandato
autoritario de su padre y las
violaciones a los derechos humanos que
aún traen dolorosos recuerdos a los
peruanos algunos sondeos le dan la
victoria a castillo a pesar de que él y
su partido estarían supuestamente
vinculados con sendero luminoso
en ecuador' guillermo lasso juró como
presidente del país convirtiéndose en el
primero no correísta en 15 años en
llegar al palacio de carondelet
precisamente en su primer día en el
cargo empezó a deshacer las políticas
del ex presidente rafael correa al
derogar la polémica ley de
comunicaciones conocida como ley mordaza
que según la sociedad interamericana de
prensa era una medida para controlar a
los medios y procesar a periodistas por
injuria y calumnia 510 medios y
periodistas fueron sancionados desde su
promulgación en 2013 el ex banquero
prometió además revivir la golpeada
economía y promover la inversión
extranjera
y se cumplen mes desde el inicio de las
manifestaciones contra el gobierno de
iván duque en colombia el reclamo
ciudadano que nació en rechazo a su
proyecto de ley de reforma tributaria
que arremetía contra la clase media y
baja derivó otra a su archivo en un
reclamo por reformas profundas que
pongan fin a décadas de desigualdad y
por garantías al derecho a la protesta
en medio de las denuncias de violaciones
a los derechos humanos por parte de la
fuerza pública que han sido corroborados
por organizaciones internacionales como
human rightswatch que reportó que más de
60 personas han perdido la vida en 30
días de manifestaciones mientras que en
un país altamente polarizado los
bloqueos en las vías han generado
críticas de algunos sectores
treinta días dos reformas archivadas y
tres renuncias de funcionarios del
gobierno después los colombianos siguen
en las calles aunque las protestas son
menos multitudinarias que en su inicio
el 28 de abril la profunda desigualdad
mantiene vivo el reclamo el paro
nacional ha obtenido algunos logros pero
aún hay cuentas pendientes como la
pobreza la corrupción y los asesinatos
de líderes sociales definitivamente
del poder no quieren escuchar por eso
seguimos aquí con resistencia estamos
pidiendo un mejor país que se acabe la
corrupción desde el de robar la plata y
que todos tengamos las mismas
oportunidades de crecer económicamente y
con educación que lo más importante el
gobierno instaló una mesa de
negociaciones con el comité organizador
de las protestas que exigía compromisos
serios para terminar con la violencia
policial y garantizar el derecho a la
protesta y es que el uso excesivo de la
fuerza es motivo de preocupación a nivel
internacional la comisión interamericana
de derechos humanos advirtió que podría
activarse una crisis a largo plazo luego
de que el gobierno de iván duque no
aceptará una visita al país de su misión
de verificación de las denuncias de
violaciones a los derechos humanos
la fiscalía da cuenta de 43 personas
fallecidas y 129 personas desaparecidas
durante las manifestaciones pero según
el organismo oficial sólo 17 están
ligadas a las protestas organizaciones
como human rightswatch cifran las
muertes en más de 60
hemos recibido denuncias creíbles sobre
63 muertes ocurridas en colombia desde
que comenzaron las protestas hasta ahora
hemos confirmado que 28 de estas muertes
26 manifestantes o transeúntes y dos
policías tienen relación con las
manifestaciones además 87 personas han
sido víctimas de violencia basadas en el
género y hay más de 1100 denuncias de
uso indiscriminado de la fuerza contra
casas y personas no manifestantes y a
pesar de los cuestionamientos ciudadanos
en contra del ministro de defensa diego
molano responsable de la policía el
congreso lo ratificó en su cargo luego
de que los legisladores de oposición
promovieron una moción de censura en su
contra mientras que algunos sectores han
empezado a rechazar el paro por los
bloqueos de vías que han generado
desabastecimiento en algunas ciudades y
la polémica muerte de dos bebés que iban
en ambulancias que no pudieron pasar
debido a los cierres de las carreteras
[Música]
se cumple un año del asesinato de la ffr
estadounidense 'george floyd a manos del
ex policía de arshavin quien se
arrodilló durante nueve minutos en el
cuello de floyd mientras él decía no
puedo respirar una frase que se
convirtió en insignia del movimiento
black life smarter que se tomó a eeuu en
protestas desde la costa este hasta la
oeste y que motivó una revisión profunda
del racismo estructural en la nación e
incluso en el mundo pues las protestas
en rechazo a casos locales y al
colonialismo se multiplicaron con el
derribo de estatuas en varias ciudades
de américa europa y áfrica
yo estoy
la familia de georg floyd se reunió con
el presidente y varios legisladores en
washington para marcar el primer
aniversario de su muerte su familia
agradeció a joe biden e hizo un llamado
al congreso a aprobar el proyecto de ley
de reforma a la policía
fue solo para recordar lo que le pasó a
mi hermano porque este fue el día en el
que fue asesinado
estamos agradecidos por lo que está
pasando y solo queremos que el proyecto
de ley de georges floyd sea aprobado
floyd fue asesinado cuando estaba bajo
custodia policial el entonces policía
derecho vine se arrodilló en su cuello
durante más de nueve minutos
chauvín fue detenido y procesado por el
homicidio la muerte de floyd tuvo
impacto en la policía en los negocios
deportes y entretenimiento tanto en eeuu
como en otros países y le dio una nueva
vida al movimiento por la justicia
racial
blacklight se sumaron las vidas negras
importantes en todo eeuu la gente le
rindió tributo al legado de floyd
el asesinato de george floyd le dio
energía y encendió un movimiento
alrededor del mundo
edwards fue generacional y multirracial
fue claro con el tiempo que llegó para
que la gente se levante y lidia con la
política
el ex presidente barack obama también
habló de eso en redes sociales hoy más
personas en más lugares están viendo el
mundo con mayor claridad de lo que lo
hacían hace un año es un tributo a todos
aquellos que decidieron que ésta a veces
sería diferente y que ellos mismos
podrían ayudar a hacer la diferencia
el presidente de byd en espera anunciar
la aprobación de la reforma a la policía
fue aprobada en la cámara de
representantes pero está en debate en el
senado donde los republicanos se oponen
al levantamiento de la protección legal
a los mandatarios
y seguimos en eeuu un rinoceronte del
zoológico de denver celebró su
cumpleaños número 12 y marcó la ocasión
con algunas notas de piano
ah
y el rinoceronte ha vivido en el
zoológico desde 2015 después de que los
reubicarán de su primera casa en san
diego componer melodías es una de las
muchas formas en las que se mantiene
estimulado física y mentalmente gracias
por acompañarme en esta emisión de aquí
américa recuerden que pueden seguirme en
redes sociales en la dirección que ven
en sus pantallas quédense en france24
hay mucho más para ver
[Música]